what we're hoping is that the by
understanding the genetic basis of the
disease that we begin to understand the
fundamental biology understanding the
disease so by exploring and
understanding which genes might
contribute to the development of
schizophrenia for example what we are
interested in finding is does this tell
us anything about the biology and the
pathways underline that and as a result
of that we may be able to find a target
so we may be able to find a maybe a
receptor or some kind of a protein that
we would be able to target with some
kind of pharmacology and then we're
hoping that because that has targeted
targeted us in on the fundamental basis
of the disease and that we've developed
some pharmacology against that
underlying basis of disease that our
drugs are more likely to be more
effective in patients with those
diseases it also may translate we hope
in the future and to be able to
targeting specific treatments towards
specific patient groups so-called
personalized medicine so helping to
understand that action fact by doing
this we may be able to find specific
patient groups who are going to respond
even particularly well to the drugs that
we develop
the concept of personalized medicine
ideally would be the right drug in the
right dose at the right time for the
right patient so in other words a
patient comes in to a doctor and a
doctor is able to do some kind of
specific screen is able to identify the
components that contribute to that
person's disease be it environmental
biet genetic or be another kind of
biological parameter in an ideal world
that would translate into one sort of
simple diagnostic that a doctor would be
able to do on the spot so-called point
of care diagnostics and by doing that a
doctor would be able to say for you with
this disorder this is the right
treatment for you you're really going to
respond to this this treatment and
you're not going to have any side
effects that's the ideal scenario that's
quite a long way off what we are doing
those were making a lot of progress in
beginning to understand particularly in
areas like oncology on cancer treatments
which of the characteristics for example
of the tumors that would make them more
susceptible to particular treatment so
we're now able to be better a targeting
or and many of our treatments in the
cancer arena to patients based on the
makeup of the tumors which we've
identified via genetic or genomic
signature and we can say you're more
likely to respond to this drug you're
less likely to have side effects and so
on and in an ideal world as we move out
into the future maybe everybody will
have their whole genome sequence so when
they come into the doctor the doctor can
read out their genome sequence and be
able to sort of say I can identify that
drug for you and be able to prescribe
the right drug for them
for the individual at the moment our
ability to translate that genetic
information at the moment into
individual risk prediction for in other
words to say that you will get a
particular disease based on this variant
is still very limited at the moment so
the technology is significantly advanced
you can do these you can provide these
genome snips the technology for
sequencing is rapidly advancing I think
their estimates up now that the cost of
sequencing of fully human genome can be
done for somewhere between maybe five
and ten thousand dollars or something
like that at the moment that cost is
going to come down and come down but at
some stage in the future we probably
will be able to crunch to a large degree
the meaning of this information and and
relate that back to an individual's risk
of disease or risk of progression of
disease but we're still quite a bit of a
bit of away from that and that's kind of
where the that's where a lot of the
debate is with for example with the
personal genomics companies which is yes
you can do this sequencing and provide
this information but how useful is that
information at the moment because how
many fill is that to the individuals so
we've probably got a bit of a way to go
with that
the most interesting thing I think about
the genetics and this is particularly in
a sort of three or four years is that
the technologies have allowed us to look
at jeans potentially contributing to
disease or contributing the risk of the
disease in a what we call a hypothesis
freeway in other words we don't know
what we're looking for we've got the
technology and we're looking without any
a priori a decision about what of what
it is that my piensan and what we're
doing as a result of that is we're
picking out things we would never have
thought of so we're finding genes that
we would never have considered it now we
don't necessarily understand that at the
moment but what that's doing and helping
us with us it's taking us into new areas
of biology so it's allowing us to unto
explore and understand biology that we
would never have thought about before so
I think that that's the one area that I
would say this is where genetics kind of
changes the paradigm of how we look at
biology where's in the past we would
have said and this is our our favorite
candidate for based on our knowledge of
the biology which we admit is imperfect
let's look at this gene and see whether
this gene is involved and that's a very
labor-intensive and it's often not been
a very successful approach but the
hypothesis freeway of being able to use
these massive and throughput
technologies has uncovered lots of
interesting biology that we haven't
thought about before and I think that's
one of the that's one of the big
learnings
you